I'm just saying if you need me I'm ready  I'll fill it if you want to see this  last year  selfie think about it I'm just as happy  attending a farmers market in West  Hollywood that's the truth  you know I'm perfect to win an award  I've already won like 15 Teen Choice  Award I got this last week for doing my  homework  yeah for cake what happened  I would love to accept this award but  Khan says I have to give it to Beyonce i  oh god I forgot it  look we're real y'all it's time to put  me in the movie of a so on it to be the  first cartoon woman to receive an Oscar  see you looking at me being Ataturk APRI  out maybe you should use my coffee why  do you say I feel like you should be the  one to say hello I just want to say a  little something even though I'm not  here a movie I like through my boy I  just really think it's great to give  second chances their chances for chances  for the chances six chances some chances  you